we were just talking about this in the
break all the extracurricular stuff we
choose to take on and you have this new
cooking show tell us about it well first
of all it's this most ridiculous thing
ever because if you do watch the today
show or you know anything about me you
know that i cannot cook like i can't
even boil water or boil an egg and every
time i go in the kitchen there's blood
like i'm always stabbing myself i once
cut myself on a pre-sliced english
muffin like it's freeze life what am i
doing with the knife why did that happen
but um for years on the today show
because these like me and cooking
segments has become like a recurrent
shtick because i'm always like saying
the wrong thing and i don't know what
i'm doing they're always trying to teach
me how to cook and finally i just said
you know what
we could do it we could do a little show
online on our streaming channel peacock
and today all day
but you have to actually let me cook
like you can't just make it all nice
like martha stewart dump this in dump
this in well who couldn't do that i
don't know how to chop an onion yeah you
know i don't know how much oil to put in
the pan it's really basic so it's called
starting from scratch perfect and double
entendre it is really really fun it's
that it's like unintentionally funny you
know it's like hi i'm savannah three i
can't cook and this is my cooking show
you know okay well this is a perfect
segue um we have some questions coming
from some of our favorite chefs to you
savannah let's see what the first
question is
hi drew and savannah it's ann varel here
hey savannah i heard that you are
learning how to cook hooray
congratulations
so i have a little bit of a question for
you maybe a quiz you could say
the first thing that i teach people when
i teach them how to cook is the term
mison plus drew do you remember what
this means from when i was on your show
before
a does it mean put in place or b mind
your plate
i know this one
this is the first thing they taught me
on the cooking show
and it just means put all the stuff in
little baskets or whatever like in cups
so that you can then it's all done and i
actually think it's really good you just
like you measure out all your stuff and
you put it in little cups
it does make more dishes so the lazy
side of me doesn't like that but it's
good especially if you're one of those
people that looks at the recipe over and
over again and mise and plus
let's see if you're right the answer is
a mise en place means put in place and
what that refers to is do all of your
prep work before you start cooking
because it takes the stress out of
cooking start there and i bet you'll
have a lot of fun in the kitchen good
luck
oh thanks ann all right who has our next
question
hi drew and savannah it's me jeffree
zakarian so i commend you first of all
for learning to cook
my question is knives it's a really
important part of my arsenal in every
chef's arsenal i'm going to ask you a
question
what kind of knife is this
what do you think is it a serrated knife
or paring knife
that is a serrated knife
that is the knife that i cut myself on
the pre-sliced english muffin i know
that knife anywhere you know that knife
intimately
all right did she get it right jeffrey's
jeffrey sagarian amazing the answer is
of course it's serrated great for
tomatoes and bread especially big loaves
of bread that are uncut and baguettes
crunchy bread it's perfect don't use it
on steak or chicken it tears the meat
it's a big no-no but for tomatoes and
bread of all sorts it's perfect
cheers to cooking
okay here's another question
hey hey everybody double r here rachel
ray so savannah i've got another
culinary question for you
so pasta
it's a super quick and easy dish of
course for anybody to make especially
newbie to the kitchen
everybody can do it
but what do you add to your water
before you drop the pasta
in and the water should always be at a
full
rolling boil
is it oil a
or b
salt
and now i'm doubting myself
i know you have to salt the water
but she said specifically right before
the pasta goes in what should you put in
so maybe you should also put in oil i
think it's a or b
well if i have to say that i'm just
going to go with salt because i i know
that salt has to be in there and the
correct answer is it's going to be
only seen you get to season the pasta
itself
and
a liberal amount of salt more than you
think you need
you want that to be similar to sea water
you should actually taste the water does
it have any flavor that's how you're
flavoring the actual product you're
putting into the water happy cooking
honey
and um we have one more oh yes
okay drew and savannah here's a good one
in order to make your pancakes or
waffles nice and light and fluffy
you do what to the eggs in the recipe
well i mean i don't know you just do
bisquick
[Laughter]
and then you crack the eggs and then
water and you stir it does it mean whisk
them
all right reveal the answer bobby the
answer is you separate the yolks and the
whites
and whisk the whites until they're nice
and light and fluffy and full into the
batter does he think i have three hours
to make pancakes
body if you think i'm separating eggs
and yolks and whites
do i look like julia child i can't do
that okay well i love your fearlessness
and i love you as a person
and we're going to get tattoos
i cannot wait
and i love you
i love you so much i love your bright
smile and your big brain and your good
heart and i'm just so lucky to be your
friend i can't believe it i love you so
much all right savannah guthrie thanks
everybody the today show every morning
on nbc and be sure to check out their
olympic coverage i'll be there we'll be
right back
[Music]